[Music]
this is
learning journey has dramatically
changed my professional life
if you ask me now a what i can do now
that i couldn't do before
there is a whole universe i can reach
now that i couldn't dream of before
[Music]
getting my google cloud certification
has really opened my eyes to the vast
world of data engineering and cloud
computing
i found google cloud to be the most
beginner friendly out of all the
different types of infrastructures that
were out there
it felt like you're cooking you know you
have the right spices
for the right cuisine
and the combination may vary for
different cuisine so it's it's an
interesting perspective
which i did not have before
certification
i'm not in a technical role and never
have been so i chose to get google cloud
certified because i wanted a challenge
and looking back now i definitely didn't
give myself enough credit so this
actually spurred me on to take several
other technical exams
getting my google cloud certification
enabled me to become the first
multi-cloud certified individual in my
place of employment
it also allowed me to work on
cloud-based solutions across the
enterprise
and become a leader as well as a more
knowledgeable and effective employee
the graphite community the googlers the
developers or practitioners
certified or not are understanding and
helpful
it's a pleasure to be part of it and to
[Music]
help
[Music]
you